- You can like maybe
trick people into thinking
you're super healthy and
drinking water all the time,
but it's just like (bleeping) coffee.
(smooth, jazzy music)
- Wow, this literally just
looks like a bottle of water.
- I think if this were a drink you ordered
on an airplane, you'd be
really happy to get it
'cause it's huge and
it looks like alcohol.
- Oh, look it, how British.
The date is written the other way.
I was like, "19/1? This is
some future (bleeping)."
- It smells like when I make coffee
at home and then leave
the pot to sit there.
Maybe a little bit like warm tequila.
- It smells like coffee.
Like it smells like espresso beans.
- Hopefully it tastes like coffee.
- It weirdly kind of tastes like vaguely
of alcohol to me.
- Something is wrong.
- Yeah, something's wrong.
- It tastes primarily like water that
once touched a coffee bean.
- I actually like it.
I really do.
And I feel more awake.
(chuckling)
- Oh, it's like a little bit nice,
'cause I like water so much. (laughing)
- But why wouldn't you just drink water?
- That's coffee flavored water.
- It's just weird that it looks so clear
'cause I really am
expecting water, you know.
- Maybe we should ice it
and try and put milk in it
and see if it tastes like what coffee is.
Has anyone done that yet?
- That looks kind of cool, actually.
Does not make it taste any different.
- I'm a person that
really likes black coffee
without any sugar and stuff
so this to me is like, this is dope.
- If it works for you, man, go for it.
Clear coffee, I don't know.
It's not for me, I'm gonna
stick with my normal coffee.
- I do know a lot of people who refuse to
drink coffee without a straw
because they're worried
of staining their teeth.
That's probably who it's
for, which is stupid.
Just live your (bleeping) life, right?
(smooth jazzy music)